o sol simboliza mais um vídeo e hoje eu
vou ensinar como fazer uma capa 47 de
papel e este aqui é o contrário das
outras de automática ou seja sobre
entregar um vídeo para disparar 2007 que
eu vou fazer equiparam 10 eu acho que
vocês conseguem ter 15 lastres
facilmente dar para vocês vão encaixando
[Música]
estava vai ser feita basicamente
utilizando tubos com antônio a 2
para isso tem que usar a fifa foi
anteriormente como folhas tamanho a3 em
volta desta maneira
no final tem que aprender utilizando
fita ou então cola e o filho no colo
porque fica mais bonita no final eu
comecei pela parte mais difícil da arma
que a parte de vocês tem que encaixar os
elásticos
isto porque vocês não conseguirem fazer
esta quarta não precisam perder tempo a
tentar fazer o resto é muito complicado
mas é parte mais difícil então de fazer
o primário do brasil folha de tamanho a3
ao mai
o scorpion e tem que dobrar o treviso e
usar cola pva não seja aquela cola
escolar porque com essa gente tem é
importante vocês deixarem ficar mais ou
menos uns 20 minutos para ficar banheiro
existente
[Música]
agora vocês têm que cortar quatro
pedaços com 35 metros e dois pedaços com
doces entender agora é muito importante
você expor em fita cola em várias partes
da rifa para que quando vocês forem a
cortar nos dizer olhem as partes
cortados
[Música]
eu vou usar esse primeiro turno aqui tem
uma caixa de redução ou seja é um cantor
que gira muito lentamente mas tem muita
força
vocês podem tentar usar os outros também
pois o problema deles é que são muito
rápidos
o melhor que você tem a fazer é criar a
vossa própria caixa de produção e tentar
adaptar à água para criar uma caixa de
produção existem vários vídeos na
internet que vocês vão encontrar
facilmente
[Música]
e um conselho que vocês retirem entorno
depois fazerem esta parte porque e
oposição estava vai atrapalhar ou seja
não vai dar muito jeito uma vez que
vocês não vão conseguir encostar a arma
totalmente contra a mesa para fazer o
carregador velocidade duas vezes o
tamanho a3
mas atenção ela estão ligeiramente
diferente daquelas no início para que
vocês têm que deixar elas ficarem
geralmente upas por dentro porque elas
ficarem lucas vocês vão conseguir
espanholas e vai ser mais fácil do mundo
aulas quando vocês quiserem
[Música]
a posição do carregador foi posta assim
mais ou menos eu e vocês podem usar uma
imagem como referência olhando para a
imagem e tenta fazer algo mais ou menos
por si
[Música]
por fazer embora da mata um sinal de uma
rifa o tamanho a3
agora é muito importante vocês fazerem
de tudo direitinho como estou fazendo
aqui e for cola onde é preciso por isso
não é só uma opção estética mas também
por uma questão de resistência
vocês vão ver longa diferença depois de
colocarem
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o conselho que vocês coloquem alguns
tubos dentro carregador desta maneira
porque vocês deixarem se nada o lucro
vai estrear se no entanto a cair e agora
como é que vocês vão pôr lá no interior
e isso é com vocês o importante é que
fique resistente e vai ficar muito
bonito porque mais para frente vocês vão
a paris utilizando folhas cobertas
[Música]
i
é
[Música]
acho
outro forçar e crone é muito importante
vocês deixaram espaços para colocar em
bateria que vocês forem usar neste caso
existe um espaço promotoria de novatos
[Música]
para fazer o pedido e vão precisar de um
arame assim mais ou menos grosso
depois precisar de um prédio com cabeça
grande e putin anunciou que a cabeça
grande e foi cumprida e que vocês têm
encurtado dois fios e aquela terra verdi
é opcional encontrei fica a imagem vocês
não tiveram não tem problema nenhum
[Música]
como vocês podem ver box por símbolos
vocês têm que fazer se uma espécie do hu
tem uma argola na ponta
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
muita atenção nesta parte vocês têm que
colocar este cabo de forma que ele
empurra aquela parte metálica para a
frente quando vocês tirarem o dedo que
time
será que basicamente quando vocês puxar
o gatilho para trás vai ligar o circuito
e um touro vai rodar e quando vocês
tirarem o teor do vídeo e que o fio vai
apurar a parte da aldeia para frente e
vai parar o movimento
[Música]
sim
o
[Música]
é
o
[Música]
se você não quiser uma bateria do volt
não tiverem conector que está uma
maneira bastante simples fazer um
precisando outra bateria não volte
[Música]
o
[Aplausos]
[Música]
o
para finalizar o vosso projecto
obesidade aquilo parte do chupa chupa
que é de plástico e para isso mas se
vocês saírem à rua procura uma criança
tiro e 1
[Música]
é uma coisa pessoal vocês depois tem que
devolver o chip é chocante porque depois
podem ter problemas enfim chegamos ao
fim eu espero que vocês tenham gostado
de isto é foi um projeto que de algum
trabalho para fazer uma vez que te fazer
o protótipo tive criei filmar e editar
fazer as rosas e quando faço uma coisa
que eu gosto bastante e não vejo a hora
de publicar o vídeo para ver a vossa
reação
gostaria também de saber uma coisa
pessoal é o próximo que vocês gostariam
de ver aqui no canal acaba 47 foi uma
das mais pedidas mas eu já fiz então
gostaria de saber qual é o próximo que
deve fazer uma coisa usem alguns
proteção na hora de brincar com o bando
mas não estou aqui pedindo o seu life
espera roubando